the author malcolm gladwell got himself
canceled last week not by me i was in no
shape to be canceling anyone of course
but uh instead he was cancelled by
everyone else from some remarks that he
made on a podcast now during the
interview on this podcast the
conversation turned to the dramatic rise
in remote work
obviously when the world went insane and
shut itself down because of covid there
was a sudden and seismic shift away from
the typical nine to five office
arrangement and towards remote work and
that trend has not reversed itself
there's no reason to think that it will
reverse itself in the future according
to estimates by people who estimate this
kind of stuff 25 of all workers in
america will be working from home by the
end of this year then in a few more
years that number will be doubled and so
on and then eventually everybody will be
working from home
this is very good news for sweatpants
manufacturers but it doesn't seem like
good news to malcolm gladwell who
provoked howls of mockery derision and
outrage
by saying this listen
as we face the battle that all
organizations are facing now and getting
people back into the office
that this
people it's really hard to explain this
core psychological truth which is
we want you to have a feeling of
belonging and to feel necessary we and
we wanted you to join our team and if
you're not here
it's really hard to do that
it's not in your best interest to work
at home i know it's a hassle to come to
the office but like
you know if you work if you're just
sitting in your pajamas in your bedroom
is that the work life you want to live
right don't you want to feel part of
something
i mean it just i
i
i
i'm really getting very frustrated with
the inability of
people in
positions of leadership to explain this
effectively to
their employees
that
um
if we don't feel like we're part of
something important what's the point
it's not you're not just doing this to
get a if it's just a paycheck then
it's like then you what have you reduced
your life to right it has to be
i don't know i guess this really is
getting me kind of i was in i was in los
angeles a few weeks ago
and um
i was
pitching some idea to a studio i went to
two studios
i won't name them
both have these beautiful
gorgeous fancy
offices of the sort you only see in l.a
right fantastic you know sun is shining
you go into the parking lot and there
are no cars there and you go into these
places where they normally would have
500 people and there are four
now they say it's because of cove it's
not coveted it's just they just did
everyone's just decided they want to
work at home
and there it is the shocking statement
that made malcolm gladwell trend on
social media for several days and
provoked reams of think pieces all
agreeing that he's an idiot a fool a
maniac not to mention a big fat meanie
for suggesting that sitting around in
your pajamas and attending zoom meetings
isn't the best path to human flourishing
the critics say that um office life you
know the critics of of mountain gladwell
say that
contrary to what he says office life is
oppressive and soul destroying and that
staying at home is clearly the better
alternative they say that it's good if
people are no longer looking for meaning
or as gladwell says belonging in their
jobs uh they accuse him of holding on to
this kind of antiquated boomer mentality
which says that the primary point and
purpose of life is to punch in and punch
out and earn a paycheck they say that's
that's no good so we're better off now
some of the critics also accuse gladwell
hypocrisy noting that the author has
over the years written glowingly about
how he enjoys working from coffee shops
instead of sitting at a desk
um and uh you know that he himself has
worked from home uh and enjoyed it
now gladwell has since explained that he
worked from home or from coffee shops as
a writer but he says that writing is a
somewhat unique profession in that
when it comes to actually putting the
words on the page there is very little
creative collaboration involved it is an
individual pursuit as an author myself i
can attest that the collaboration if you
can call it that happens after you've
already written the thing and you hand
it over to editors and they collaborate
with you by picking your work apart for
months on end word by word as you
silently pledge to yourself that you'll
never make the mistake of writing
another book again
but according to gladwell
most jobs don't work quite that way and
so most workers would benefit from being
in an office environment even if he as
an author did not
which seems like a reasonable
distinction to me but what do i know
so who's canceled here
well it's not malcolm gladwell his day
may come to be canceled but it's not
this day instead it's his attempted
cancellers who are canceled for two
reasons principally
first it's this
whether gladwell is right or wrong
the point he's trying to make here isn't
unreasonable he's making a perfectly
salient observation and raising
justifiable concerns even if he's
missing the target by an inch or two in
one direction or the other there's no
reason why anything you heard in that
clip should elicit anything close to the
sort of reaction it received
moreover whether good or bad or some
combination the shift away from
in-person collaborative work and towards
remote work facilitated by video
conferences is a dramatic and
consequential change it's a change that
significantly impacts the way people
actually live their lives on a
day-to-day basis what this means is that
at a minimum if we're a rational and
intelligent people we would realize that
this is a change worth talking about and
we would be eager to consider the
pitfalls and listen to what the critics
have to say about it
but we're neither rational nor
intelligent which means that any opinion
slightly outside of the mainstream is
automatically treated as not only wrong
but totally insane and not worthy of
consideration
we have as a culture almost no ability
anymore to wrestle with ideas
instead we have one idea on a particular
subject and we will not engage any ideas
that challenge the one idea we will
instead scream at the challenging idea
and spit at it and spit at it and throw
things at it and stomp our feet until
the idea goes away
and because we have the memories and
attention spans of fruit flies we're
able to apply this strategy to even the
most seismic cultural and societal
shifts because once the shift takes
place
we immediately take for granted that
this change has happened and we decide
that we couldn't possibly do things
differently from how we just started
doing them five seconds ago
a person who advocates for a return to
the way we did things five seconds ago
is treated then like some sort of freak
from outer space or like a time traveler
from the ancient past
but by defending the merits of working
collaboratively in one physical space
with other people gladwell is simply
articulating what has seemed obvious to
most everyone in the modern industrial
age
even if he's wrong there's nothing
radical or irrational about that
trying to create a society where people
stay on isolated islands
never coming into physical contact with
the people they're ostensibly working
with that's what's radical
it's a massive social experiment and
there's no way to know if it will
actually work out for the best because
human society has never tried anything
quite like this
and that brings us to the second point
and this is the thing that most people
as usual seem to be overlooking
is it good for companies for employers
to have their employees scattered to the
wind connected only by email and zoom
calls
well it seems pretty clear that the
answer is no it's not good for employers
but gladwell wasn't just talking about
what's good for companies he says it's
not good for the individual it won't
make you a happier a more fulfilled
person to forsake the office in favor of
your couch and your laptop he says that
remote work is bad for you as a person
because it deprives you of the
opportunity to feel like you're part of
something it takes meaning and purpose
out of your life he says
now here
gladwell's critics are are seemingly on
a stronger footing as they can rightly
observe
that you shouldn't be depending on your
nine to five for meaning and purpose
there are other better places to find
your sense of belonging in the world if
you work from home they say you can
invest more of yourself into your family
into your community you can develop
other hobbies you can develop other
passions you can you know grow and
become a more well-rounded person
you could start doing other things you
can read more books you can maybe start
a vegetable garden or something you can
exercise more you can you can put your
job in its rightful place as a source of
income
but not look to it for anything more
than that
for meaning and purpose and belonging
you can reach to deeper sources
and that's all true
that can be a benefit of working from
home
i work from home for years okay so i
know something about that
but here's the important question
is that what most people are actually
doing
so as we splinter off and isolate and
live these increasingly remote and
fractured yet technologically dependent
lives working from home ordering meals
and uber heats having our groceries
delivered having everything else
delivered interacting with the world and
other people through screens primarily
etc
as we do this
are we in general
using all of the extra time that these
conveniences afford us to connect more
deeply with our families and develop
different skills and passions and to
pursue knowledge for its own sake
the answer for most people is no not
even close
most people just spend the extra time
staring at screens
the screens have enabled them to give
more of their lives to screens
working from home saves them from
wasting time on commutes and pointless
office gossip but all of the extra time
they're given is returned right back to
the same piece of technology that gave
it to them
indeed all the evidence available to us
tells us that for the most part
though we have a lot more time to
connect with our families and share
meals and read interesting books and do
interesting things
we are not actually doing any of those
things more in fact we're doing all of
them far less than we ever have
the more free time we have the less we
accomplish with it that's the general
societal trend here
in theory
the shift towards working from home
could be an enormous boost for human
flourishing allowing us all to re-center
on what really matters in life
but in practice it's been mostly a boost
to the streaming services and social
media platforms that have been the
primary beneficiaries of all this
surplus free time
so in theory
working from home could be in many ways
a superior arrangement but in practice
most of those people really would be
better off in the office
and that was a very long and winding
road just to finally say that malcolm
gladwell is only half right which means
that his critics are also half right
but they're more annoying about it and
so today they are the ones who are
finally
canceled
and that'll do it for us today actually
no that won't do it for us today we're
going to go to our new segment that we
just unveiled but you have to be a
member to watch it so we'll
see you over there
hey i know you're craving some more matt
wall show content well i have some great
news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com and subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast i'll see you there